wie heißt du alice was willst du
erzählen
quäle mich wenigstens
Bewohner von Mariupol
also bin ich dabei
[Musik]
das Herz der Unschuldigen hat begonnen
Passwort
hier ergaben wir uns, aber es war zu versorgen
in diesem Moment das Knie selbst in Schwierigkeiten
oskolki
Beschuss und unser Markt war schon unangenehm
für denselben Verein
Wir versuchen es gerne
nicht nervös und wenn sie auf schießen
die Struktur bricht
[Musik]
das ist also meins
Die Situation dort ist komplex und kann es sein
tragisch
aber
Sie ist nur ich, eigentlich bin ich heute hier
sprach mit dem Barden des Präsidenten
Er erzählte den Gunns, was sie dorthin wollten
Kämpfen dort ist kein Kämpfen
nicht beendet
[Musik]
geplanter Angriff
Industriegebiet
unpraktisch
Ich befehle Ihnen, die Blockierung aufzuheben
Industriegebiet, damit die Fliege
Feind
[Musik]
Wir müssen von hier evakuieren, wir sind friedlich
Anwohnern ist das schon löffelweise passiert
war entspannend hinter der Kneipe ganz in der Nähe und neu
Farbton
[Musik]
Ich bin der Kommandeur des Oberstleutnants des Asowschen Regiments
Dennis Prokopenko versteckt sich vor o
leuchtend und fahrpreis direkt für zeit fabrik
Azovstal kommen in Hunderten von Zivilisten
romadin von Verwandten ist reich an Kindern und immer wieder
vika welpe sprue menschen etwas familien
Verteidiger in der Nähe von Mariupol diese uvays und Verstand
Russische Welt in den Kellern gibt es eine Bombe mit
Gemüsekerl im ukrainischen Visco Sie
waschen weiter Planeten Orte er
unangemessen verdeckt kannst du dort springen
Russischer Insasse steht im Laborantensaal
dnr mit dem wissen wissen sauberer hier ist der zivilist nicht mit
Wenn ich in der Luftfahrt bin, stört es mich nicht, Bunker nicht
Bomben werden Raketen abfeuern, das ist es für alle
offensichtlich oder Kreaturen werden darin bombardiert
einschließlich bald geblasener Dramahöhle
Likör Schulflaschen nicht mädchenhaft
der Gärtner wurde geheilt und du bist, was wir jeweils sind
über puna im bespeco dann kannst du das ganze
Evakuierung niemand sicher Tomoya zeigen
zum Anklicken von Politikern aller Zivilisationen
Gefolge organisiert und der grüne Korridor ist notwendig
es garantiert bespeco Schulungen durchzuführen
Evakuierung von zivilen Verwundeten und Leichen
getötete Krieger und Schüchterne, aber ich schlecht nicht
mit ehren
[Musik]